at like 200 people say ask him about his
real voice I'm like what does that mean
is that an inside joke nah it's real
what they think your voice isn't real
what uh I really what the [__]
that's not how you really talk that is
my real voice I just talk like this when
I'm trying to like make music and make
content and [__] but I really talk like
this in real life
get the [__] out of here you can ask
anybody that's how I really talk damn I
can't do that I can't read you at all
bro usually I got people within the
first couple minutes but yeah I know
that's what everybody said
[Laughter]
you might be the greatest actor of all
time oh yeah
this whole time he's gonna come and take
his hair off like by the way guys
you get